[Music]
you were just in Ireland were you not
yes I was
we're in Ireland were you I was in
Belfast which is Northern Ireland and
it's actually where Game of Thrones is
filmed did you get to visit the the set
Game of Thrones cuz I would think you'd
have some cachet with the Game of
Thrones people so here's the deal I was
I was like I'd never been to Northern
Ireland before I was very excited about
this trip and the first thing that comes
into my mind is Game of Thrones and as
we're landing I'm literally humming out
loud the game of Thrones - Wow
so it was just a thing so I'm the nerd
so I did actually manage to get a chance
to visit the set which was pretty
mind-blowing what did you see on the set
that was well I actually got to sit in
the the Iron Throne you sat I mean I on
the Iron Throne is this correct did you
bring evidence of this that you have a
photo yes I want to see you sitting
there you are you don't look too
menacing
[Laughter]
I don't know what that pose yeah I don't
know you're supposed to like I'm trying
to be serious yeah like I own this line
you look like you're waiting for a bus
all right here it'll be here soon
in the meantime cut off that guy's head
to see everything we got to go through
the sets the costume department the
props actually got a Winterfell candle
very excited about I don't that just
isn't that just a candle as it turns out
it is just a fact I don't think you got
ripped off here's a winterfell
microphone
[Laughter]